hopes are fading that any more survivors
will be found
in the rubble of a collapsed apartment
complex in florida
now reports have emerged about an
engineer warning of major structural
damage to the building three years ago
so far officials have confirmed five
deaths but more than 150 people
are still unaccounted for
a makeshift memorial has sprung up in
the suburb of surfside
to the scores of people engulfed in the
rubble of the collapsed apartment block
search and rescue teams are working
around the clock
probing their way agonizingly slowly
through the shifting mountain of debris
a fire burning deep beneath the rubble
is complicating
efforts the fire is deeply
seated deeply rooted under the structure
so you've seen it in and out and
unfortunately we keep
having flare-ups of it and it's just not
accessible
so those are the difficulties that's
another challenge that we're
encountering and
you know we're constantly going in
aggressively trying to get as close as
we can to
to extinguish that fire but
unfortunately we haven't been able to
get that extinguished 100
yet but rescuers and the people of
surfside refuse to give up hope
full speed ahead on search and rescue
and you ask
why do we have hope we have hope because
that's what our search and rescue team
tells us that they have hope and as long
as they can do that and as long
as they have encouraging signs like the
knocking sound
that they've heard then we will continue
volunteers at the surfside community
center are giving what help they can to
survivors
as the tense wait for news of loved ones
continues
people are starting to demand answers
surfside council has revealed that an
engineering report in 2018
had detailed structural failures in the
building but the building managers were
still shaping plants for a repair
project
that was set to get underway quite soon
for those trapped under the rubble it
was not soon enough
well dw's carolina chimoy is following
the story from washington d.c
so carolina what more do we know about
this report
well apparently three years before this
happened a consultant found alarming
evidence
of major structural damage in that same
building the building is 40 years old
and the engineers report
showed plans for a very expensive a
multi-million dollar repair
project that was set to get underway
soon but this did not
happen obviously and the report detailed
significant cracks
and breaks in the concrete in the walls
which
required repairs as soon as possible to
ensure the safety of the residents
and of the public around the building
now the mayor of
miami-dade county or this building is
announced a 30-day audit for all
buildings
that are 40 years and older under the
county's jurisdiction
now there's clearly growing pressure on
authorities to explain how this disaster
happened
what have they been saying
they are all of course under pressure
because server side uh conno and and and
other structures in that same
area um they are trying they are all
afraid they are shocked by these images
and and they're trying to see if their
buildings might
be in the same situation the mayor also
said they want to make sure that
every building in that area has
completed their uh
certification and recertification
process
that is due after 40 years and that they
want to make sure to move
quickly to remediate any issues that may
have been identified in that process
but these pictures are also shocking for
people who are not only in that county
but in the miami area especially for
families um
who have of course been witnessing um
how difficult it is not only
talking about the infrastructure but the
personal loss that
families living in this building have
had i mean the fact that um
the people who are rescuing there are
still hearing
people knocking in the rubble is of
course uh
shocking and sad at the same time
because they do want to rescue them
but they're running out of time and this
is pretty obvious yeah
time is running out here and i'd love to
get your thoughts then on how
the rescue efforts are currently going
right now what is the status there
well they say they still hear tapping
sounds under rubble
but at the same time we have heard about
the fires that are going
uh down there and this of course
would make a whole perhaps a bit smaller
for them
but we already heard it in the report
they don't want to give up
a pope and uh the fire right now there
is of course a totally dis
disaster for the ones who might still be
there and might have
survived uh the crashing of this
building
okay karina chimoy monitoring that story
for us
from washington dc thank you